TRANSGENDER ATHLETES.
JEDEDIAH?
JILLIAN: THANKS, WILL.
AS SMALL BUSINESSES WORK TO
REOPEN THEIR DOORS AFTER
PANDEMIC LOCKDOWNS, THEY ARE
RUNNING INTO A NEW PROBLEM,
BLOATED UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
ARE ACTUALLY HURTING THEIR
ABILITY TO GET EMPLOYEES BACK TO
WORK.
JOHN MICHAEL IS THE OWNER OF
ROCKING TACO IN GEORGIA.
HE IS SEEING THE PROBLEM
FIRSTHAND AND JOINS US NOW.
JOHN MICHAEL THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
I LOVE THAT RESTAURANT NAME BY
THE WAY IT’S PRETTY COOL.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
LET’S ASK YOU, WHAT HAS BEEN THE
IMPLICATION ON YOUR BUSINESS TO
THESE LONG-TERM UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS THAT PEOPLE ARE
RECEIVING.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
AS WE ARE OPENING BACK UP, WE
ARE STARTING TO SEE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN PATIENTLY WAITING TO
GET BACK OUT AND THEY ARE
EXCITED TO GET BACK OUT BUT THAT
ALSO MEANS THAT WE ARE SEEING AN
INFLUX OF PEOPLE THAT NEED TO BE
TAKEN CARE OF AS GUESTS WHEN
THEY COME TO THE RESTAURANT.
IT’S BEEN IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND
SOMEONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO WORK.
RED JED SO WHAT DO YOU THINK AS
A BUSINESS OWNER IN WHAT SHOULD
BE DONE HERE?
OBVIOUSLY YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE COMING OUT AND
SAYING THAT MANY SUFFERED AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC AS A
RESULT OF GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWNS,
OF THE ECONOMY, OF BUSINESSES SO
THOSE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS ARE
NEEDED.
SO YOU HAVE TO WEIGH THE TWO
THINGS.
WHAT WOULD BE YOUR PROPOSED
SOLUTION AS A BUSINESS OWNER
RIGHT NOW?
>> ONE I AGREE THAT PEOPLE DO
NEED THE MONEY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN GET ALL THEIR BILLS
PAID AND MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
FOOD ON THE TABLE BUT AT SOME
POINT AFTER THE STIMULUS CHECKS
HAVE GONE OUT, PEOPLE ARE MAKING
MORE ON UNEMPLOYMENT THAN WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO PAY THEM TO
COME OFF OF UNEMPLOYMENT.
SO, THE BIGGEST THING THAT WE
HAVE SEEN IS THAT PEOPLE DON’T
WANT TO WORK FOR THE MONEY WHEN
THEY CAN MAKE JUST AS MUCH OR
MORE SITTING IN THEIR HOUSE SO
AT SOME POINT, I THINK IT’S
SUPPOSED TO EXPIRE IN SEPTEMBER
BUT THAT’S THE END OF THE
SUMMER.
THAT’S AFTER ALL THE RUSH HAS
COME IN.
SO, IT NEEDS TO BE SOME KIND OF
PLAN WHERE WE SLOWLY ROLL BACK
THESE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS SO
IT FORCES PEOPLE TO SAY, HEY, WE
ARE PACK OPEN.
IT’S TIME TO GET BACK TO WORK.
JEDEDIAH: YEAH, THAT’S AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION THAT
WE’RE HAVING RIGHT NOW ABOUT
WHETHER WE ARE DISINCENTIVIZING
WORK AND WHAT THE IMPLICATIONS
OF THAT WILL BE LONG TERM.
ONE THING THAT’S REALLY
INTERESTING ABOUT YOUR BIOTO ME
IS THAT YOU ARE ALSO A FINANCIAL
ADVISER.
WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO A
LITTLE BIT WHAT YOUR SEEING FROM
THAT ANGLE IN TERMS OF WHAT
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY DOING WITH
STIMULUS MONEY WHEN IT GETS IN
THEIR HANDS?
ARE THEY SPENDING IT?
ARE THEY INVESTIGATING IT?
INVESTING IT.
>> INVESTING IT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN’T NEED IT
OR WEREN’T EXPECTING IT AND ALL
OF A SUDDEN THEY GET A STIMULUS
CHECK IN THEIR CHECKING ACCOUNT
SO, THEREFORE, THEY ARE
REINVESTING IT.
THEY ARE PUTTING IT INTO THE
STOCK MARKET AND SOME OF
THESE -- DIFFERENT GAME STOPS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
THAT’S THE NUMBER ONE CALL WE
GET IS HEY CAN WE GET ON SOME OF
THESE HOT STOCKS AND THAT’S NOT
THE WAY IT WORKS.
LESS PEOPLE ARE PUTTING THE
MONEY INTO THE ECONOMY WHICH IS
WHAT THE PURPOSE OF IT WAS.
BUT MORE PEOPLE ARE DEFINITELY
USING IT TO INVEST IN THEIR
SAVINGS.
THAT’S DEFINITELY I HAVE SEEN.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY ADVICE TO
PEOPLE FINALLY FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF A BUSINESS OWNER?
WE HAVE HAD A LOT OF BUSINESS
OWNERS ON THE SHOW WHO STRUGGLED
AND WE CAN ALL UNDERSTAND WHY
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC.
BUT ADVICE TO THEM FROM A
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE AND A
FINANCIAL ADVISER PERSPECTIVE
RIGHT NOW IN THESE DIFFICULT
TIMES AS THE ECONOMY STARTS TO
REOPEN AND PEOPLE HAVE SOME
TREPIDATION ABOUT WHAT TO DO AND
HOW TO APPROACH IT BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT SURE WHAT’S COMING DOWN
THE PIKE IN THE NEXT FEW MONTHS?
>> OH, I MEAN, ABSOLUTELY.
EVERY BUSINESS OWNER IS WALKING
ON EGG SHELLS BECAUSE THEY DON’T
KNOW IF THERE IS MORE MONEY
COMING TO HELP THEM OR IF IT IS
GOING TO BE THE END OF IT OR IF
THEY JUST NEED TO OPEN BACK UP
WITHOUT LIMB LIMITATIONS.
WE ARE WAITING ON THAT WITH THE
STATE OF GEORGIA WHICH I FEEL WE
ARE VERY CLOSE.
THE BIGGEST THING IS TO HOLD ON.
I FEEL LIKE INTEREST IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
SITUATION THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE GOING THROUGH.
HOLD ON, TRY TO FIND THE
EMPLOYEES, TRY TO MAKE THE GUEST
HE IS HAPPY WHEN THEY COME IN.
BUT IT’S -- I FEEL LIKE WE ARE
GETTING TO THE END, SO DON’T
GIVE UP ON US NOW.
JEDEDIAH: JOHN MICHAEL BRUNETTI.
THANK YOU, I LIKE A LITTLE ROCK
WITH MY TACO SO IF I’M EVER IN